i think if you just maybe tried harder
oh i tried
i talked to a therapist i talked to my
mother i read every book possible
i took a love seminars i took sex
seminars none of it worked
i tried everything except telling you
what was bothering
me that's the first thing you need to do
you know you go to a therapist you go to
your mother but what about the person
who you have the problem with
let them know i'm losing attraction hey
gq i'm stephanie yates ibuy
a marriage and family therapist and this
is the breakdown
[Music]
first up marriage story you're being so
much like your father do not compare me
to my father
comparing our spouses to
their parents that's a low blow
especially if you know
that they have this desire to be
different from their parents
when you try to attack a person's family
member and compare them
the reason why that's so cruel is
because they probably shared those
things with you in a moment of
vulnerability when things were going
well
so now what you're doing is taking
things they share with you in confidence
and throwing them
in their face and it's really hard to
recover from that
at this point we're just trying to win
the argument they're not trying to hear
each other the point of a good healthy
argument is to walk away
understanding your partner's point of
view people used to tell me that you
were too selfish to be a great artist
and i used to defend you they were
absolutely right
all your best acting is behind you
you're back to being a hack
you gaslighted me so what he's
describing here
is one of the things that couples
therapists are always looking for which
is an
atmosphere of criticism we're seeing
contempt here which contempt is
basically
trying to be superior to your partner
belittling them he's talking down on her
acting she's calling him self-absorbed
all of these things to just throw
daggers
and what he's saying is that she was
always critiquing him
and a lot of times in relationships it
is important for you to think about that
balance of encouragement and support
versus criticism i mean we'll never
really know what the full dynamic was in
their relationship
but for those of you who are in
relationships always be aware of that
balance
someone else i shouldn't be upset that i
should be upset
that i had a laugh with her do you love
her no
but she didn't hate me you hated me you
hated me
just want to quickly hear talk about the
importance of when you are
in an argument try to focus on using the
i
position and what that means is don't
speak
for your partner or whomever you're in
an argument with if we can even call
them partners at this point
but saying you hated me you did this to
me
you're telling somebody else how they
felt instead of maybe phrasing it as a
question
i felt like you hated me is that true
giving them the opportunity to explain
either you know verifying what you said
or not i can't believe i have to know
you
forever you're [ __ ] insane
he was trying to direct a punch not to
her and so i view it a bit differently
than i would
in a moment where you have a couple
where somebody's literally trying to
intimidate someone
i view this as him trying to relieve
some aggression so that it's not
pointed toward her and you wanted so
much
so fast i didn't even want to get
married
there's so much i didn't do thanks for
that
you're welcome rushing into a marriage
absolutely
can lead to resentment but that's not
the only way and it's not a guaranteed
way to become resentful what ends up
happening with resentment is when we
make
a lot of sacrifices and compromises
without communicating to our partner
that these are things that we
really don't want if he really didn't
want to be in a committed relationship
or get married
those things should not come up later
after the decision is made so resentment
often happens when things take a turn
and we're reevaluating all of the
compromises and sacrifices that we made
throughout the relationship
that we never communicated we felt we
were giving a part of our identity up
for
in an argument when you see yourself
as the victim and innocent and your
partner as the person who
has done everything you're victimizing
yourself that's not a healthy productive
way to approach any relationship or
conversation
you want to come from a place of
accountability because as a marriage
therapist
i'm never looking for who's right and
who's wrong
often what happens with couples is they
start developing
dysfunctional patterns that they both
play a role in
you have your job and then they have
their job and the system just repeats
itself
and so what i'm looking for are the
patterns and if i
have couples where the person is like
just pointing the finger
playing the blame game then i'm probably
gonna look at okay well this is part of
your pattern is that you start pointing
the finger
and then you guys end up in these kind
of altercations
you're such a dick every day i wake up
and i hope you're dead
dead like if i can guarantee henry would
be okay i'd hope you'd get an illness
if i get hit by a car and die
this part makes me sad honestly i think
people have different reactions to these
kind of revelations
because we really just don't know if
it's true i think what he's trying to
communicate
is this conversation this experience of
going through this divorce
has hurt me so bad that i want the pain
to go away
and he thinks the only escape would be
to lose her but ultimately
i believe that would probably bring him
more pain and so it makes me
sad that this is the only escape that he
can envision at this point in his life
i see this scene a bit differently than
i think some people would see where they
would just get mad and say how dare you
be so cruel
it is cruel absolutely but it is also
heartbreaking
i hate when i see couples like this not
end up together
in the end because there was so much
love i don't think that he really wanted
her dead not at all
i'm sorry me too
so that is probably the truest moment
that we saw in that scene is that moment
where even though
they've just said the ugliest things
they could to each other
he collapses into her and she cuddles
him
when i'm looking for patterns with
couples this is probably a lot of their
dynamic
he gets really up in flux she goes to
caretaking and nurturing
and that's how they both ended up
compromising and sacrificing so much
throughout the relationship that they're
now very resentful
it really just shows how heartbreaking
it is that they didn't end up together
we definitely know that divorce rates
have gone up
over the years i don't think that that
has to do with people sticking it out i
think it has to do more with access to
resources
and the family structure kind of
supporting people you know you had a
woman who typically was financially
dependent on a man for example and
to leave him would mean to forge a new
path that for a world that was really
not designed for her to be
providing for herself i look at it more
as now
people just have so much more access to
other options and i think we have a hard
time in this culture with commitment
we have so many things via social media
dating apps
we're always wondering if things could
be better and maybe they could but
in a relationship like the one we just
saw where there's still a lot of love
i have a lot of hope for those sorts of
relationships
next up bridgerton
would you please ask miss nolan if my
personal effects have yet been removed
from the duke's bed chamber
just provide a little context here
essentially they're upset with one
another because
she wants children and he doesn't want
children
and she feels like he lied to her in
order to achieve his goal of not having
children
and now they're in a position where she
may be pregnant
by tricking him that's why there's a bit
of tension here in this scene
kids is one of the most important
things that you need to know before you
get married if you're like i'm 50
50 on having kids don't be with someone
who's 100
don't get with someone who has told you
they don't want kids with the
expectation that you can change them
and don't know that you may not want
kids and think oh i'm just so in love
that i
might ultimately end up changing my mind
for this person
because both of those things are
sacrifices
for a lifestyle that will ultimately
lead to resentment
no matter how you look at it when it
comes to deception
in a relationship the reason why this is
such a tricky thing is because
ultimately it betrays trust trust is one
of the
hardest things that you can rebuild in a
relationship
i know people who had some major lie
that was told or some trickery that
happened 20 years ago
that still come up in arguments it's
always better
even if it's a very very uncomfortable
conversation
to make sure you are sharing with your
partner what's going through your mind
and the things that you want to try
especially the things that will
inevitably affect the both of you and
while we're talking about
deception and we're talking about
especially like matters to do with sex
listen male or female consent is consent
so
make sure that you're not making
decisions on behalf
of your partner that you all are having
conversations
about what you're wanting to see next in
your future together
could you please ask miss nolan if my
personal effects have yet been removed
from the duke's bed chamber
would you please inform her grace that i
will allow no such thing
i just want to pause here because this
is a great example of triangulation
which is where you have so much tension
conflict or anxiety between a couple
that they bring in a third party to help
relieve
some of that tension when they are
basically
playing telephone instead of talking
directly to one another
it's a way of saying i'm not comfortable
talking to you i'm going to
punish you by not speaking directly to
you
a lot of us have been that friend where
you've got a couple that's arguing
you're getting called or you just happen
to be there
you know you hate those moments and
they're wanting you to pick a side or
tell them that they're right is this
going to
give you the results that you want in
the relationship which is to have
healthy communication and get to the
other side of this argument
so if you're being triangulated in try
your best to resist
but if you're in the relationship and
you're pulling your friends in just know
that that's a sign
that you guys have built up a lot of
tension
so much so that you're having a hard
time managing it just between the two of
you
i absolutely do understand completely
why
he is frustrated with her anytime we
feel tricked by somebody we're not going
to
have happy feelings about it but on the
other hand i totally understand
her feelings too if you feel lied to
that's also not going to make you feel
good so i do think that they both have a
right to their feelings but if they
would just have some honest and open
conversation
they'd be able to see that both of them
are just really misinformed about the
other person's experience
you cannot believe i shall welcome you
back into my bed after your lies and
deception
rest assured marital relations are the
least of my concern after your recent
efforts
then for what other purpose could you
possibly wish to detain me because you
are my wife
people could have different takes on
this but i actually
think him saying because you are my wife
i think that is almost an olive branch
because what he's trying to say is
i care about you i don't want to sleep
apart from you
and if we can find a space in our
arguments to say
you were my partner we plan to do this
together i love you
those kind of words even out of anger to
explain
your purpose it can really bring down
a lot of the tension in an argument and
you see
when he says that there's a moment where
she's taking it in like
she still likes to hear that he's
referring to her as his wife
it is customary for a wife to reside in
her own bed chamber once the honeymoon
is over
i will be kept informed as to the
success
of your conjugal endeavors i would never
dream of concealing the truth of such
important matters
now granted she did already do some
deceptive things so it's not like she's
in the clear here
but i will say in this particular
argument that was a good response
don't worry i would not keep that
information from you that's a really
important way of saying i still care
about you
and i care about how you feel yes you
guys
what has happened my brother seems to
have been embroiled in scandal
i must return to see my family
immediately they will need me i will
accompany you this is a family matter
separate bedrooms may be tolerated
separate households will not be suffered
i want to pause just because again he
doesn't want to see
his marriage fall apart and even though
she
might be picking up on that because
again you saw that little hesitance
when he said that you know she probably
liked that she's trying to brush past it
and hold on to her anger
but in reality i would assume that that
makes her pretty happy that even when
she's pushing away and being difficult
he still has a desire to be with her
i think it's really important here that
we're talking about
a family matter and her saying this is
something
for my family once you marry someone
that person is on the family tree so
they are a part of your family
it's really helpful that you don't think
of them as separate
from your family those are some of the
predictors of a successful marriage
is when we can see that good integration
of your partner and to your family
your partner is there to support you and
the family
when they can and i think that that is
what he's doing here
the fact that he says if there's an
issue i'm coming with you
that's letting somebody know i have no
intentions of abandoning you
i shall not let you out of my sight
until we know whether you are with child
please request that his grace prepare
his largest carriage
i should require my space do i think
he's really trying to monitor her
conjugal efforts no because she's
probably not going to be able to conceal
it
and has already confirmed with him that
she has no intention to
but he's just using it as a crutch
because it seems to be the only thing
that works for him to not have to create
even more distance between them
as she's requesting so again i think
he's being open
i think he's still being loving towards
her
and even though she's frustrated and
upset this is one of those couples where
if they were arguing like this i
walk out of the session like they're
gonna make it
next up the office
can you not do that it's disgusting
you know i have soft teeth how could you
say that oops
you don't want to criticize your partner
in front of people
that's a sure way to lead into an
argument most of the time
when we criticize our partners in front
of an audience
there's a new layer of embarrassment and
it makes them question
why you're criticizing them in a
relationship you want your partner to
feel like if you're saying something
negative about them
it's constructive you're doing it
because you love them and you care about
them
try to reserve criticism for your
private alone time
so that it doesn't seem spiteful and
hateful
oh hey babe yeah how about we take the
beer sign down until our guests leave
and then we can discuss it
no no i'm gonna leave it up i think it
ties the whole room together
first of all we could tell that that was
a very passive aggressive
interaction they were having there and
what does passive aggressive mean
passive aggressive is when we're not
saying what we want but we're trying to
manipulate a person into doing what we
want
without really expressing that so saying
things like
you can if you want to when really want
to say please do
so i want to talk a little bit about
that sign that he put up because it's
deeper than just being spiteful
why in that moment did he choose to put
that sign up
whenever we're in the midst of
transition that can be
very anxiety and stress provoking if you
watch the office you know that
she has lost her job she just moved in
with him
they're a relatively new couple all of
this transition
really leads to a lot of stressors in
the relationship and so when we start
experiencing transition and stress as a
unit
trying to find our identity as an
individual and our identity in this
relationship
what do we do we typically revert back
to our old self that's more comfortable
so he's literally saying you treat me
unfairly you're unkind to me so i'm
going back
to what i usually have up in my home i'm
putting the sign back up
you're not worth the sacrifice and
compromise of not having up my sign if
you treat me that way
so be very careful of that when you're
in the midst of changing
within your relationship this is a
relationship that i would say
kind of reminds me of when you have a
leech
i think that jan uses michael for
whatever
she can in the moment he's a very
amicable and malleable
person so he's flexible to whatever she
wants but as we see in this scene
when she doesn't treat him kindly he's
starting to get frustrated and upset
because he's recognizing
all of the sacrifices that he's making
for her so i would say this is a toxic
relationship
not that it couldn't possibly work but
there has to be some love there and
things in the relationship that aren't
just
material that she's gaining out of it
for it to work
a toxic relationship to me is one where
you by being in the relationship end up
having
less self-confidence you end up
questioning your own goals and dreams
and you feel sometimes trapped in the
relationship as though you can't get out
everybody's definition of a toxic
relationship is different and it's
really popular term now
but those are the main things i'd look
for before i would say that a
relationship is toxic
and i'm a candle maker but you don't
hear me bragging about it
man i would love to burn your candles
you burn it you
buy it it's all started with that
criticism
in front of an audience that's how this
whole thing has escalated
he's making fun of her candle making
business that
seems to be the final straw for her is
him coming for something that she has
not yet developed a confidence
or identity in when you know that your
partner
is trying to endeavor on something that
is unfamiliar territory
and you told them that you're going to
support them picking at their failures
or picking at them when they
are still trying to get on their feet
those are things that they don't forget
so don't give them yet another thing to
stress about when they're already trying
something new and different and
uncomfortable
that is a 200 plus your screen dvd you
just
killed good luck paying me back on your
zero dollars a year salary plus benefits
babe
whenever we're having a passive
aggressive fight or it escalates to
destroying property
i mean this is very immature even doing
it in front of people
that's an immature way to handle
conflict in your relationship
so it really reminds me of like when
you're on the playground and you like
throw a stick and they throw a stick
back that jab for jab tit for tat type
of arguing
again the point of a good argument is to
walk away
understanding one another's perspective
if you're just trying to win the
argument then you both already lost
if i was at this dinner party and i pray
to god my husband would be there too
we would use this as material for
laughing for years to come
when you argue in front of people you
know you really are just giving them
reasons to look at you differently
you're not just embarrassing your
partner so keep that in mind
too next up euphoria
who hasn't been in the position where
you're trying to
write something and you want to use the
perfect
emoji the perfect words the perfect
acronyms
to really get your sentiment across and
i think
it's really good to highlight here
sometimes we really do need to think
about the medium
in which we're going to communicate
certain things some people really do
communicate better
via text because they have an
opportunity to look at what's been sent
to them
process it and then get their words
perfectly
before they respond and sometimes if you
just can't figure it out
maybe think about choosing a different
medium the timing with an argument
is highly dependent on both of your
conflict resolution styles
you have some people who really work
best talking about it
in the moment so they can remember
everything that they were feeling
and they can communicate that in a way
that feels authentic
and fresh and other people like to have
time to process what's happened
and think about what they need to be
accountable for
so i always say if you have even one
person in the relationship that needs
to take that pause always take the pause
because if you force that person
into having the conversation when
they're not ready you're going to end up
either in a shouting match or they're
going to completely shut down
and neither one of those options is
productive
i don't want to fight with you i don't
want to fight with you either
you have to understand that i just want
you to be safe okay
i just i don't want anything back to
happen to you
i love this clip so much because
it's a wonderful example of a vulnerable
and transparent
conversation opening up with i don't
wanna fight with you
that is listen my weapons are down
i want to have an open conversation with
you where i can understand your
perspective and share mine
also i think it's important here a lot
of these things that zendaya is
communicating you wouldn't be able to
see that via text or on a phone call
look at how far away she is look at what
she's doing with her hands and fidgeting
she's looking down
all of those things are communicating to
jules that
she's having a hard time saying this and
it helps her develop more empathy in the
conversation
you know you just can't be mad at me for
wanting you to be okay
because i'm being anxious that's a
vulnerable thing to say because
basically she's saying even this
conversation makes me really really
nervous
and when we can hold space for our
partners not even being comfortable
talking to us
we're really on track to something good
they're not even a couple here yet but
they're already doing
amazing couple communication that hurts
my heart too much
i just i i don't know it's the best
thing that's happened to me in a really
long time and i just i
i just don't want anything bad to happen
so just please don't be mad at me okay
joe
i'm sorry i want to talk too about
her recognizing in that space and
distance and that body gesturing
how uncomfortable she was she knew that
it was okay to close the gap
and give her a hug sometimes that's all
our partner needs
you know they're up in flux they're
going crazy and they just need a
reminder
like i'm not going to abandon you i'm
not going to reject you for being
anxious or being nervous
or getting upset i'm going to be right
here with you and i'm going to help you
process this
that's exactly what she communicated
with that hug and
i mean this is just amazing conflict
resolution which is why i love this clip
i love you you really do
whenever we have developed a fondness
or a good relationship with someone and
that word i love you comes up especially
if we have feelings it's helpful
sometimes to ask for clarification
be assertive when i say i love you i
think of you as my person
i kind of envision a future for us and
see if they're on the same page
that's the only way to really be clear
about
if it's a miscommunication or not we
have to
be willing to have those difficult
conversations so that we get more
certainty and clarity
i'm sorry so you never know when you go
for that big moment it's going to be a
risk for any of us that first kiss that
first i love you
and we don't know you know somebody
could say oh they were misreading
signals or mixed signals she was giving
if she wasn't okay with the kiss
but we really don't know she might be
just taking some time to process what
happened
and i think they end up getting together
so clearly it wasn't that far off the
mark
but yeah i mean that moment her anxiety
got the best of her and she ran out of
the room but
i'm curious if she would have stayed if
they would have just had a good
conversation about it and maybe
expedited the process to being together
the only time
i view it as wrong is if you go for that
and the person says i am not comfortable
with that
do not kiss me or they don't give their
consent and you try to go for it again
that's absolutely a problem but with the
level of vulnerability that they've
established in their relationship
clearly they can be physically close
going for that kiss is just a risk that
she took to see if it could be something
more
with our earliest relationship
experiences those really set the stage
for our later relationship experiences
if we're lucky we end up staying with
that person forever and we have
really good communication with them we
never have issues but more than likely
what's going to end up happening
is life gets in the way they have so
many transitions ahead of them
graduating high school maybe going to
college
they probably won't stay together that's
typically not what happens
but if they are able to do a good job
being there for one another
communicating well with one another that
really sets the standards for who's
allowed into their space and later
relationships i love this clip because
this is such a good example of healthy
communication where they both just
wanted to express
why they cared about something and hear
the other person's perspective
being open being vulnerable because
honestly miscommunication is the number
one
reason that couples fight most of the
time that's what i'm listening in for
and once we figure out the
miscommunication patterns
usually i can apply it to 10 different
subjects that they've brought up in
session
next up malcolm and marie why didn't you
cast
me
when you first wrote it you wrote it for
me i want to pause here
because the way she opened the
conversation
this is the vulnerability that we need
to see
for us to make it to the other side of
an argument
she's being honest and saying the
question that i have is why
didn't you cast me she's hurt that she
was a part of the process
that her life is what this story is
built from
and she's not saying it in a mean way
she's doing it in an open-ended
question which is a great way to
communicate with our partners she didn't
say
you should have casted me she asked why
didn't you cast me
and instead of him responding we see
here
that it's met with contempt so that's
what this whole thing has been about
tonight
no [ __ ] you're lying yes it is
that is not accepting the olive branch
when our partner
is trying to be open with us he just
says so that's what this has all been
about
that's a very different response that
really causes your partner to shut down
so then when he says isn't it her
response is no
it could have been yes because it's
probably a vast majority of what has
been bothering her
but because he put his guard up now hers
is back up as well
this opening line of her being
vulnerable it reminds me of the euphoria
clip
and it's a stark contrast in how jules
responds to her versus how
malcolm does he responds to her by
bringing another
issue to the table and critiquing her
criticizing her for not saying it sooner
instead of appreciating the fact that
she's being vulnerable and
open and meeting that with a safe space
for her so they can have healthy
and good communication as far as him
casting her i think
some people might look at it that way
and say had he just casted her they
wouldn't have all of these issues
right but there are fundamental
breakdowns in this relationship that
caused them to argue
and weaponize and be critical of one
another so i don't think that him
casting her would have solved all their
problems
as a matter of fact her working in the
movie might have led to even more issues
in their relationship
the problem is the way that they
communicate with one another and i think
that
if he could just tell her i
would have loved to have you in the
movie i knew you would have been
great in it that could have solved this
argument
i was in that audience
and i thought to myself wow
i did not mean to give all of that away
and i don't want to get into all the
reasons why you cast taylor
if you see from the beginning of the
movie
marie is very big on arguing about one
thing at a time
and that is a really important aspect
of good conflict resolution she said i
don't want to get into all the reasons
why
you cast taylor earlier in the film she
even says let's not have this argument
we're tired we're hungry so she seems to
be a little bit better at paying
attention to their cycles and trying to
prevent them
but he kind of pulls her back into that
cycle a lot of times
and they end up having these hours-long
arguments
so often people have no clue
how their actions impact their partner
there are some things that you do
want to pay attention to but a lot of
times things go over our head we say the
wrong thing we do the wrong thing
but we have to be in a position and
willing to be accountable when our
partners try to communicate to us
how something made them feel and often
what we do instead is
go straight into defense mode trying to
convince the other person
that that's not what we meant that's not
what we did that's not how they feel
instead of saying i didn't realize that
i made you feel that way
and i'm really sorry how can i help
fix it leave it to you to spend the
entire night burning it all to the
ground only to reveal that in the end
you're just
jealous i'm not jealous yes you are all
right
of course you are welcome the feeling
that i'm feeling right now is deeper
than that
here he's trying to tell her how she
feels she's
actually sharing a lot with him about
how she feels
how about instead you deal with what
she's already
shared with you about how she feels and
maybe you'll get to the jealousy
but why don't we deal with what she's
already bringing to the table
which is that she's hurt i think there
are so many different
understandings of jealousy i think from
a very simplistic
understanding sure of course there's a
jealousy there that
she had to endure seeing another woman
in her place
playing her role then that same woman is
on the arms of her partner while they
are revealing this project to the world
and she's not
in the forefront i don't see why she
wouldn't be jealous
i think jealousy has such a negative
connotation
that a lot of times we don't really want
to admit when we're jealous
but being jealous is a part of the human
experience and you can use that to
inform the direction with which you want
to take your actions
if seeing that for example did make her
jealous then maybe it's time for her not
to be
a retired actress and start pursuing
projects as an actress again that
jealousy can actually
inform us about a lot in terms of our
wants
you didn't try and that's the harsh
reality of all of this that same
instinct that exists in the mind
and you the instinct to self sabotage
that didn't go away i didn't try because
you didn't want me
now you want to play the video
now you want to say you felt like i
didn't want you so you didn't try
so often we are in a place of trying to
win the argument
that we don't even recognize that we're
talking about the same thing
she's saying she wishes she was in it
he's saying he originally planned for
her to be in it
and he didn't think that she really
wanted it that's a miscommunication
this is an opportunity for them to have
a conversation and reflect on that
the fact that i can't tell my story
anymore
i can't articulate oh chaos that's going
on in here because you already
but the difference is you were able to
take all that clean and make it
something beautiful
i'm very impressed with her ability not
to stoop
to that petty arguing that he is trying
to incite
she's still complimenting him she's
still telling him he made a beautiful
piece of art she didn't say and what you
created was crap and it would have been
better if i was in it right because she
could have taken that approach
if i were to see this argument in
session i would challenge him
and say wait before you bring that up
what do you think about what she's
saying about her story being told
could you see why she would feel like
that opportunity was taken from her
those are the kind of questions asked in
therapy that will break up this type of
dynamic
because then he has to answer my
question which is essentially what she's
already been asking the whole time
next step for getting sarah marshall
listen i
get it okay i just i need to understand
what i did to make you cheap i just
let's pause here there is nothing you
can do to
make a person cheat they make that
decision to cheat on their own
even if they're dissatisfied with the
relationship they could break up with
you you cannot make a person cheat so
your first question shouldn't be what
did i do
we've seen couples be able to recover
and come back from cheating
think it boils down to their values if
it's more important to you to make it
work
if you can let them know what they have
to do to build
trust back up in the relationship then
sure we can see a couple survive
cheating we see it all the time but i
will say it's really really hard to get
your trust
back to where it was before you cheated
because in the back of that person's
mind they're always gonna wonder
are you still cheating i think if you
just
me try it harder oh i tried
you have no idea how hard i tried peter
i talked to a therapist
i talked to my mother i read every book
possible i took a love seminars i took
sex seminars
none of it worked i tried everything
except telling you what was bothering me
clients do this all the time they'll
tell me this big thing
and i'll say and what did they say when
you told them
oh i haven't told them that's the first
thing you need to do you know you go to
a therapist you go to your mother but
what about the person who you have the
problem with
let them know i'm losing attraction when
it comes to
effort in a relationship that is so
subjective
it really boils down to like love
languages i think a lot of times so you
might have one person
who's like words of affirmation which
means they feel really good because a
person says nice things to them
and they're expecting that from their
partner as effort
while as the other person might be acts
of service and they want to see you
doing things
taking action washing the dishes those
kind of things to communicate your love
so when it comes to putting in effort
there's a good chance your partner may
not notice your effort
because that's not what they're looking
for so it's good to
let them know this is how i feel love
this is how i perceive effort
and ask the same of them so that you
guys are on the same page
about what effort looks like to each of
you i couldn't
drown with you anymore don't you dare
sit there and tell me that i didn't try
i did you were just too stupid to notice
i do want to take a second here to talk
a little bit about the concept of
letting yourself
go because you know it's hotly debated
if people are thinking
i should love this person based on who
they are
not what they look like but physical
attraction is an important part of what
initially attracts us to someone and
it is important to try to continue to be
attractive to your partner
now i'm not talking about things like
weight because sometimes we don't really
have control
over those things but maybe tending to
your hair
making sure you're grooming yourself
taking showers those kind of things
sometimes we really do stop putting in
effort and it can
impact our relationship and it will
impact our relationship so i do
understand where she's coming from
but her main mistake was not saying that
to him
and saying it to everyone else instead
of him one of the things that we'll hear
all the time with relationships is you
go through this honeymoon
stage and then once the honeymoon stage
is over can you sustain the relationship
i'll be honest i don't think the
honeymoon stage has to end
but if you are in one of those
situations where
you don't look at your partner the way
that you used to
if you're just dating it's okay to say
that and it's okay to break up
if you're in a marriage a marriage is
lifetime commitment
that's what we're targeting and hoping
for you have to try to communicate that
to them and
see how long you stay outside of that
honeymoon stage
because it's really not just you're in
the honeymoon stage in the beginning and
then it's over
you can go through ups and downs of like
you're dealing with a lot of stress
so you don't feel all of these happy
hormones all the time with your partner
you have to kind of be committed to the
process you shouldn't be with the person
just because they make you feel good
because that might not last forever
thanks so much for watching stay tuned
for part two
we'll be breaking down more scenes of
couples fighting